the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that
the dance of the dragons was a war
unlike any other ever fought in the long
history of the seven kingdoms
though armies marched and met in savage
battle
much of the slaughter happened on water
and especially in the air
as dragons fought dragons but this was
also a war that was fought in the
shadows and stairwells
council chambers and castle yards the
dance of the dragons is a
great name for these major conflicts
within house targaryen that nearly
destroyed the realm
but an even better name would be the
dying of dragons
before the dance of the dragons began
house targaryen had
18 dragons but when it was all said and
done
nearly all of them as well as the
targaryens
had died after they essentially devoured
each other
this once great house would never be the
same again
as you all know hbo is set to release
their new series house of the dragon
in a little over a year as of right now
we don't know that much about this show
but now that hbo has hired one actor to
fill the shoes of one of their major
characters
we can start to get a sense of what this
new series will be about
the very first slot they filled was king
viserys targaryen
and this is what leads me to believe we
will absolutely see the dance of the
dragons
in my opinion everything i discuss in
this video will be seen in house of the
dragon
over 100 years after aegon targaryen
conquered westeros
this viserys targaryen set on the iron
throne
now like most men who become the king
viserys
had hoped that one day he would have a
son who could take over the seven
kingdoms after him
although viserys and his wife made
several attempts
they were never able to successfully
have a son who would live long enough to
succeed him
viserys did however have a brother
daemon targaryen
also known as the prince of dragonstone
now since viserys had no sons
his brother daemon considered himself to
be his brother's
heir for the iron throne although
viserys did love his younger brother
he did not want him to become the king
viserys was still hoping that his wife
would give him a son
so they could settle the issue of
succession rather than name his brother
daemon the heir
he gave him a seat on the small council
instead
well this did not go over well with the
hand of the king
sir otto hightower the king's brother
daemon
and the king's hand serado did not like
each other whatsoever
but viserys wasn't about to get rid of
his hand so he got rid of his own
brother instead
now viserys gave his brother a new job
he made him the commander of the city
watch
sir otto was still worried though
because he thought if something did
happen to viserys sometime soon
then daemon would become the next king
anyway so this is when cerrado suggested
that maybe viserys should name his
daughter rhaenyra
his heir since he has yet to have any
sons viserys did not like this idea
though
because he still thought his wife would
give him a son eventually
well what do you know one day his wife
ema
did have a son but unfortunately she
died during labor
and then their new son died the very
next day
when his brother daemon found out what
happened he made some jokes about how
his son was only the heir for a day
now although daemon was drunk when he
made those jokes
it still made viserys very angry this is
when he decides that serato's advice
might not be that bad after all
viserys has this amazing ceremony where
he names his daughter rhaenyra
the heir and the princess of dragonstone
obviously his brother daemon was furious
he left king's landing immediately
afterwards
viserys made sure his daughter was right
by his side
he wanted to show her how things were
done so she would be ready for the iron
throne
now this is where things begin to get
very interesting
you see although a lot had happened in
his life already
viserys targaryen was still a young man
he wasn't even 30 years old yet
so the grand maester as well as many
others
thought that viserys should get
remarried viserys did like this idea so
that's exactly what he did
he married the 18 year old alison
hightower
who was the daughter of serato hightower
his very own hand of the king
now it's said that alison even got along
very well with his daughter rhaenyra
during the wedding feast alison kissed
her on the forehead
and named her daughter that's right life
was good in the capital
but this new marriage did not make
everyone happy
when daemon targaryen found out his
brother remarried
he savagely beat the man who brought him
the message
it was so bad that man almost died as
of right now viserys's daughter rhaenyra
was still the heir to the iron throne
but that did not last for very long his
new wife alicent
who was extremely fertile gave him his
first son
who they would name aegon then only a
few years later
she gave him a daughter helena and only
a year after that
allison gave him another son who they
named aemond
this was not good visceras who once had
no heirs for the iron throne
now has several now the relationship
between his wife alicent
and his daughter rhaenyra began to
fracture
they both wanted to be the first lady of
the realm but this obviously will not
work
although viserys now had sons he still
wanted his daughter rhaenyra
to follow him in the line of succession
he figured the matter was already
settled because he had named his
daughter in his will
however this is when alicent and
rhaenyra became rivals
in what is known as the blacks vs the
greens
his new wife allison represented the
greens because she was known for wearing
a green dress
his daughter rhaenyra represented the
blacks because she was known for wearing
the colors of house targaryen black and
red
there were many loyal supporters ready
to fight for their respective side
some did believe that viserys and
alison's son aegon should be the heir
while others believe rhaenyra should
remain the heir since this is what
viserys wanted after all
well as soon as viserys died they would
have to settle the matter like
targaryens often do
with fire and blood i believe this is
when the first season of house of the
dragon could end
similar to game of thrones the first
season could end with the major death of
one of the major characters which
is what eventually sparks all the wars
across the kingdoms
anyways when one of the servants found
viserys's dead in his bed
he ran to alicent to inform her of what
happened
now usually when something like this
happens they would have to ring the
bells in the city to let everyone know
that their king is dead
then they would send a raven to
dragonstone so they could inform
viserys's daughter raynera
who would then come to the city for her
coronation since she was next in line
for the throne but alicent wasn't about
to allow that to happen
as soon as she saw her husband's dead
body for herself
she locked the doors then she had the
servant thrown into the black cells
before he could have anyone ring the
bells
or send the raven to dragonstone this is
exactly the kind of thing cersei did
when robert died
so she could ensure that her son joffrey
would sit upon the iron throne
later that same night alice sent and the
commander of the kingsguard
sir kristin cole held a small council
meeting to inform them
of the king's death sir otto hightower
who was the hand of the king
and father to queen alicent demanded
that the succession be settled
immediately the small council wasn't
sure what to make of this
they thought the matter was already
settled since viserys named rhaenyra his
heir
this is when the commander of the
kingsguard sir kristin cole says
well the son should come before the
daughter
they argued about this for hours that
was until the master of coin finally
stands up and basically says
he will not betray viserys so what does
sir kristen cole do
he opens up his throat in front of the
others this ultimately settles the
debate
viserys and ellison's son aegon would
now be the king
they held his coronation in the dragon
pit of king's landing
his wife and sister helena would now be
the queen
it seemed as though allison had won not
only was her son the king
but even her daughter was now the queen
viserys and allison's other son
aemond left king's landing on his dragon
to go find other supporters
who hadn't already sworn fealty for
their new king
the banner of the black and gold dragon
flew high over king's landing and the
red key
as aegon second of his name ascended the
iron throne
but he would not sit there for long when
the news finally did reach
dragonstone rhaenyra assembled a meeting
of her own
there with her was her uncle and now
husband daemon targaryen
brother to the late king viserys daemon
was considered to be one of
if not the most dangerous man in the
realm
rhaenyra only had a handful of lords who
supported her
but the greatest of these was corliss
velaryon who had the largest fleet of
ships in the realm
his wife rhaenys targaryen also had a
dragon
by now rhaenyra also had five sons of
her own
but none of them were a man grown just
yet now
although rhaenyra may not have had as
many supporters as alicent
and her son aegon the king she did have
something that gave her an incredible
advantage over her adversaries
rhaenyra rainey's and her husband daemon
had
massive dragons three of her five sons
had dragons as well
but that's not all there were six more
dragons on dragonstone that still needed
riders
so again although rhaenyra may not have
had the numbers
she certainly had the firepower armies
can take
and even hold cities but dragons can
burn them all to the ground
in the new king aegon only had four
dragons whereas rhaenyra had about a
dozen
rhaenyra was also hoping she could get
the support of the few great houses not
already sworn to the new king aegon
her oldest son jacarys flew to the vale
in the north
her middle son lou careys flew to the
stormlands
if rhaenyra could get these great houses
on her side this would be an amazing
start
when rhaenyra's son luceries arrived in
the stormlands
he was shocked when he saw king aegon's
younger brother aemond
was already there by the sight of lord
baratheon
now this was thought to be the safer
mission but aemon was already a fearsome
man before he lost his eye
and set a sapphire inside its socket
although
aemon had beat him there lucario's did
what he could to get lord baratheon on
their side
it would not be enough lord baratheon
chose to side with king aegon
and his one-eyed brother aemon targaryen
aemon sapphire eye
gleamed at lucaris as he fled from the
castle and mounted his young dragon
iraq's there was a storm falling down on
storm's end
at that very moment luke harris and his
small dragon struggled as they were
flying through the hard sheets of rain
and bright bolts of lightning the loud
thunder cracked and snapped as the sound
of another dragon
shook the very foundation of storm's end
suddenly
the one-eyed aemon targaryen rose
through the clouds on his monstrous
dragon known as veigar
not only was his dragon several times
bigger but aemon's dragon was already
the survivor of a hundred different
battles
aemond in his dragon veigar unleashed
their attack
above shipbreaker bay it wasn't long
before lucerus and his dragon fell from
the sky
only to be swallowed up by the waves
below
now the war of fire and blood began
when rhaenyra received the news of her
son's death she
instantly collapsed she actually
considered
ending the war right then until a raven
brought her a letter from her husband
daemon
the letter said her son would be avenged
daemon actually knew a spymaster in
king's landing
who also happened to be his mistress
thanks to this spymaster
daemon and rinera were able to avenge
her son's death
by hiring assassins known as blood and
cheese
one of these men just so happened to be
a former gold cloak
in the other a rat catcher and the red
keep knew all of the castle secrets
so one night blood and cheese were able
to infiltrate the red key
while king aegon's wife helena was
helping their small children
into bed the assassins came into their
room
each with a dagger in hand they said a
debt was owed
a son for a son they actually allowed
helena to choose what son she wanted to
die
now she did try to convince these men to
kill her instead
only they didn't listen finally helena
decided that the younger son maelor
should be the one to die most likely
because the older boy was king aegon's
first born son
and heir you hear that little boy cheese
whispered
your mama wants you dead only it was the
older son who lost his head
what was once a small dispute has now
turned into a war
of total annihilation the grief and rage
of losing a child could burn down the
world
either aegon or renera could live at the
end
but not both shortly after this rhaenara
would strike again
only this time she would take one of
their greatest castles in the riverlands
when the lord of harrenhal saw daemon
targaryen above his castle when his
dragon karaxis
he struck his banners and surrendered
however
this wasn't all that rhaenyra would
accomplish thanks to her other sons
winterfell and the vale had declared for
rhaenyra
this made alicent and king aegon furious
aegon immediately fired his hand of the
king serado hightower who also happened
to be his grandfather
this is when he made sir christian cole
commander the kingsguard
his hand instead sir kristen swore that
he would immediately march on those who
declared for rhaenyra
he said he would burn their castles down
to the ground the new hand of the king
and the royal army first went marching
to the north
when they arrived they laid siege to
rook's rest
one of the black strongholds near
dragonstone when the lord of rook's rest
saw king aegon's armies outside
he sent a message to rhaenyra begging
her for help
he had to sit there and watch as his
fields and villages burned
as there was no word from rhaenyra that
was until the day a shadow was seen in
the sky
flying over the green army rhaenyra sent
raineris instead
as well as her dragon as her ancestors
had done at the field of fire
rainey set fire to sir kristin cole's
army but king aegon had set a trap
right as rhaenys and her dragon were
raining fire down on his army
two other dragons rose into the sky it
was aemon
on vegar and the king aegon himself on
sunfire
believe it or not rhaenys did not flee
from the fight
it was as if a second sun formed in the
sky as dragons fought dragon with fire
when it was all said and done only
aemond and his dragon veigar were
uninjured
one of the most incredible looking
dragons sunfire had fell from the sky
the once new king aegon was stuck
underneath sunfire crushed
he was broken and burned some of his
armor had melted right into his own
flesh
somehow he did survive as well as his
dragon sunfire
but they would never be the same again
rhaenys however
was burned completely and now nothing
but ash
her dragon also died as it was ripped
into shreds
now after this happens rhaenyra gets a
little concerned
so that's when she sends her youngest
sons across the narrow sea
hoping that would keep them safe not
only has she lost one son already
but now they're losing dragons only a
few days after sending her youngest sons
away for their safety
one of them comes back with his dragon
severely injured
him and his other brother were attacked
by an enemy fleet just outside of
dragonstone
this is when rhaenyra's oldest son and
heir jacarys
mounted his dragon vermax and flew so he
could rescue his other brother
and set fire to the enemy fleet this
doesn't end well though
jacares and his dragon vermax get hooked
like a fish and dragged into the sea
no one knows what happened to the other
brother he and his dragon were never
seen again
rhaenyra's advantage was beginning to
fade now that she's lost four dragons
luckily for her though she had six more
dragons on dragonstone
but she would have to find riders for
them dragonstone
also had a lot of targaryen bastard
children running around as well
so rhaenyra offered them gold and titles
to any of the bastards who could ride
the dragons
into battle the dragons killed several
of these bastards before they could even
attempt to mount them
but for the dragons did accept their
riders they were immediately enlisted
into rhaenyra's army
now the king aegon was badly broken from
the battle at rook's rest
his brother aim on one eye took over the
army
he was the blood of the dragon and now
he wants vengeance
he marches the king's army right to
harrenhal to take back the castle from
rhaenyra's husband daemon
however when amon and sir kristen cole
arrived at harrenhal
they realized daemon and all of his men
were now gone
they had assumed that daemon had fled
the castle rather than fight
later that night they feasted their
victory at harrenhal
they had no idea what daemon was about
to do
daemon decided he would much rather have
a different castle
so as amon onei and kristin cole were
marching their army to harrenhal
daemon flew carrax's south right to the
gates of king's landing
since the one-eyed amon had his dragon
veigar and the king's army at harrenhal
the city was now defenseless rhaenyra
was now ready to take back what she
believed was rightfully hers
the city fell without a fight the small
council handed over alison
and her daughter the queen helena but
now the broken king aegon was gone
somehow he had vanished from the city
now the king's landing was hers
rhaenyra was finally able to sit upon
the iron throne
after losing several sons and dragons
rhaenyra finally had what she wanted
all her life however when the one-eyed
aemon
realized his arrogance had lost him the
capital he mounted veigar
and burned every village and castle he
suspected of disloyalty
aemon had basically abandoned his army
therefore
sir christian cole had to march the army
back to king's landing
he was hoping he could retake the city
by himself but he would never make it
there
the riverlords who had sworn to support
rhaenyra would find him
now sir christian cole did attempt to
challenge the lords to single combat
but they denied him instead they filled
him with arrows
the army he once commanded was destroyed
thereafter
a new army of green supporters laid
siege to the city of tumbleton
rhaenyra sent a few of her bastard
targaryen dragonriders in hopes of
burning them all
they did burn the city but they also
burned all the black supporters
garrison within that city the bastard
targaryens had betrayed rhaenyra
this gave rinera good reason to suspect
that all the bastard targaryens were
disloyal
the only issue was her own husband
daemon was sleeping with one of the
targaryen bastards known as nettles
as soon as rhaenyra heard about their
relationship she was furious
rhaenyra sent a raven demanding that the
girl's head be sent back to her
and daemon should come back to king's
landing immediately
when daemon found out rhaenyra wanted
her head he allowed the girl to escape
the disappearance of nettles made
rhaenara even more angry
daemon then sent a challenge to his
nephew the one-eyed aemon
instead of leaving for king's landing to
go be with his wife
daemon flew his dragon to harrenhal
alone looking for a fight
after waiting for nearly a fortnight a
massive black shadow swept over
harrenhal
aemon and his dragon veigar had come at
last
he laughed at daemon for facing him
alone daemon mounted his dragon
but he neglected to fasten the chains
that secured the rider to the saddle
right as the sun was beginning to set
both dragons leapt into the sky at once
daemon swiftly took caraxies up into the
sky until they disappeared into the
clouds
vegar who was the older and more slower
dragon
ascended more gradually aemond and
vegard were
searching searching and searching until
as sudden as a thunderbolt
a shrieking karaxis dove upon veigar the
dragons locked together and fell to the
lake
karaxi's jaws closed around veigar's
neck
but veigar's claws opened up keraxi's
belly
then daemon targaryen who had never
fastened his riding chains
stood in his saddle he'd leapt from his
dragon to aemons
and in his hand was dark's sister the
valyrian sword of aegon's sister queen
visenya
as aemon one eye looked up in shock
daemon ripped off his nephew's helmet
and drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye
so hard it came out the back of his
throat only half a heartbeat later
the dragon struck the lake the lake
boiled with dragon blood
and then was still the battle above the
god's eye ended
in the deaths of both riders and both
dragons
unlike the one-eyed aemons body however
daemons was never found
back in king's landing king aegon's
sister wife helena
flung herself from the balcony window or
maybe she was thrown
who really knows but either way she was
dead
later that night the city began to riot
in the streets against rhaenyra
they demanded justice for the death of
helena and her slain son
during all the chaos a one-handed man
begin to demand that the dragons should
be killed
not only those of the enemies but all of
the dragons
especially the ones that are in the city
locked away inside the dragonpit
he said that's where the demons live
this is their city
and if you want to make it yours then
you first must destroy them
thousands of rioters begin to descend
upon the dragonpit
on this night there were four dragons
locked away inside
when the rioters made their way inside
the dragons were already awake
and very angry nobody knows how many men
and women died that night
but in the end it did not matter they
were able to kill
all four of the dragons that were inside
rhaenyra who was standing atop the red
keep
was watching as all the men and women
were ending what once made her house and
name
so feared it was as if she was too
afraid to defend her dragons against
those who would harm them
however one of her older sons joffrey
was not about to sit there and watch as
his family's dragons died
so he mounted his mother's dragon cerax
and tried to fly it to the dragon pit
but the dragon shook itself free of him
causing the young boy joffrey to fall to
his death
rhaenara was now feeling completely
broken
considering all that she's lost rhaenyra
then abandons the iron throne
and sails back to dragonstone she was
hoping that she could hatch the dragon
eggs that were within the castle
but she never had the chance when she
arrives on dragonstone
her guards were immediately slaying in
front of her and her last remaining son
rhaenyra was shocked when she saw who
was waiting for her
inside the castle the broken and burned
king aegon
who had vanished from the city as well
as his dying dragon sunfire
were awaiting her rhaenara who was still
defiant
said that she had hoped her brother was
dead after you
aegon answered then his dragon
sunfire covered her in his reign of fire
then he devoured her in only six bites
while her only living son had to sit
there and watch
rhaenyra was now dead and king aegon set
upon the iron throne again
but only for about half a year he was
eventually poisoned by his own men
then he was replaced by the boy who had
to watch his own mother burn
and get devoured when rhaenyra's last
son wed
aegon's only daughter the dance of the
dragons officially
ended this was all that was left of the
once mighty house targaryen
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen this is essentially what
happened
during the dance of the dragons now as i
was saying before
i fully believe this is what we will see
in the new hbo series house of the
dragon
i think this would make for one hell of
an amazing show
now as you all know hbo has already
hired one actor
who will fulfill one of the major
characters from these events
because of the choices king viserys
targaryen made
and the actions of his children it leads
to one of the greatest
and tragic events in westerosi history
if you enjoy videos like these and you
want to stay up to date on house of the
dragon and the winds of winter
make sure you subscribe because i
release several videos a week
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching i really hope you come back for
my next video
have a great day everyone i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you